[Music]
Korea Beginnings as a stand-up comedian
a legendary character played across 10
different shows Law and Order Special
Victims units icon Richard Belzer is
dead at 78. keep watching to find out
about his life and the heartfelt
tributes after his passing The Hollywood
Reporter confirmed on February 19th that
the actor and comedian passed away early
Sunday morning in his Southern front's
Home a close unidentified friend of the
actor revealed that Belzer has been
suffering from quotes lots of health
issues news of the actor's death on
Sunday shocked the industry including
his closest friends and colleagues
actress Lorraine Newman was the first to
post a tribute for her late friend on
Twitter she wrote I'm so sad to hear of
Richard bellza's passing I loved this
guy so much he was one of my first
friends when I got to New York to do SNL
we used to go out to dinner every week
at Sheepshead Bay for lobster one of the
funniest people ever a master at crowd
work R.I.P dearest Newman and Belzer
previously worked on The Midnight
Special variety show together and met
during their time on SNL former SVU
showrunner Warren lights also commented
on the news of Belzer's death on Twitter
he wrote Richard Belzer was the first
actor to welcome me when I started at
SVU open warm acerbic whip smart
surprisingly kind I loved writing for
Munch and I loved being with bells we
sensed us would be his parting scene
godspeed Bells Bowser was most known for
his work as detective John Munch on the
Law and Order universe who later became
a sergeant at Manhattan's SVU he
appeared in a whopping 326 episodes
throughout 15 Seasons alongside Mariska
hargate and Ice-T who played his
longtime partner Finn tutuola Belzer
also appeared in the original Law and
Order and Law and Order trial by jury
Munch first appeared on NBC's homicide
life on the streets but moved to SVU in
1999 while Richard Belzer's most iconic
role was John Munch the actor began his
career in entertainment as a stand-up
comedian according to people Belzer was
hired as a warm-up comic for the
audience at Saturday Night Live in 1975
and was adamant to Lone Michaels
promised him a spot on the official cast
but that never came to fruition he only
appeared in three episodes but was never
an official cast member in the early 80s
Belzer appeared in very small roles in
Scarface and the TV series Miami Vice
among others he also landed a role in
the 90s The Flash series where he played
Central City Reporter Joe Klein for 10
episodes following the actors passing
several of his fans on social media
recounted wrestler Hulk Hogan's Infamous
appearance and the Belzer's talk show
hot properties to promote WrestleMania
while showing off his moves Hogan put
Belzer in a Chokehold eventually
dropping him according to the New York
Times Belzer would go on to sue Hogan
out of court while his brief beef with
Hogan made the comedian famous it was
his gig as one of television's most
notable cops that made him a household
name Landing the roles of munch on
homicide life on the street in 1993 was
undoubtedly Belzer's breakout role
despite working in the industry for
almost last 20 years at that point the
character even had a crossover
appearance on the X-Files in 1997.
additionally Munch would show up on 30
Rock Arrested Development and
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt to name a few
Bowser's pension for comedy could be
seen in his performance as much as his
back and forth with Finn tutuola was
utter Perfection Munch always had a
smart comment waiting to come out and
often brought tension among his tightly
wound colleagues belza will be missed